thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another careful boys
where we are very careful boys and it's
the Attitude Era we've been going ham on
each other no it's 2023 you gotta come
come up with a gentleman let's get the
classical era yeah oh the classic
just got started last year no I made
another one but I forgot what I was
realized what the engineer is they're
all talking about it I gotta run with it
this year but it's every year has to be
a different era is what I'm saying no
you can't do a different era every year
the error is
marked by decades a couple years dude
it's like a bunch of like a block of
time welcome to this video this is where
we talk about what era it is we have
annual eras yeah no we're gonna okay
today's prompt is we're talking about
what type of relationship did your
parents have with your ex and was that a
thing was that an issue oh with our ex
significant other ah oh yeah see good
[__] yeah my mom liked all of my exes oh
[__] she thought one was a hooker but
that was it really who was that why the
most girl one no I was in high school
she's like can I talk in high school and
it yeah and I was like Joe it was a wild
boy she was like you know it's probably
not a good idea to like
bye girls and I was like
I was like I was like hold the [__] up I
was like I'm listening she knew your
nature back then first off you don't
think your son can [__] pick up women
that I had to go buy them and like
second all why would you think they were
hungry she goes oh I know how a hooker
dressed like and I'm like that's [__]
up because you're just discriminating
these young girls fashion that's right
it's different from your fashion I was
hella defensive I was like they're not
hooker all right they might be easy they
might
be easy they might be they might like
they might like party
and by the way we're seeing each other
sounds like so she's not a hooker okay
do you think the hooker's like what
and the mom's talking to her friends
like my son fell in love with the [__]
he seen the same one he was buying her
over and over and over yeah and so that
was a that was a really awkward
conference conversation you said you
were in high school I was like 17 or 18.
okay so you're old enough to be able to
buy a hooker maybe yeah you could you
could afford a home he was just like
probably not a good idea to buy these
girls and I was like what the [__] are
you saying she had no faith huh I guess
in her mind
like girlfriend material don't like
sleep around yeah so she just comes from
a different era yeah so was this girl
you're bringing her home and you guys
were like sleeping together yeah or like
whatever like she stayed like a few days
yeah but I just I was with someone like
a couple months ago so she probably
thought I was just like rolling in
different girls what does your mom just
relieved because you weren't like trying
to [__] your pillow anymore look at that
point
she should have been like I'm proud of
you son you're not [__] your pillow
anymore but then now she's still talking
[__] because now she thinks I'm just
[__] hookers how'd you break it off
with the pillow
it wasn't easy it's not he's like look
at about the couch yeah it's not you
yeah it's me it turns the cushion around
still hooked up they just weren't
together hey we had fun huh yeah it was
a great era yeah yeah I'm moving on to
women now every air is a year
yeah yeah yeah
thank you for being my stepping stone
imagine imagine that's amazing imagine
you know what because of the language
barrier though my mom never had a real
friendship or relationship you're
talking about your pillow still with a
pillow that one is a they're not that
was pillow yeah I think that's one of my
favorite parts
like having your parents not being able
to communicate with the their exes is
the best yeah because David wanted a
Korean girl so they could communicate
with his parents and I'm like wow why I
wanted to keep them separate when I was
when I was uh 16 the girlfriend I had at
the time my dad swore I should have
married her and all she did was like
bake me a carrot cake for my birthday
it's a big deal though wow that's not
easy to make she's like she really cares
about you and I was like we've only been
dating for a month and we're both 16.
and then you should have married maybe
back then though there was that was like
yo man she could cook she beat you a
cake that's wifey material maybe but I
was like man my dad's tripping
I was kind of like that too if I was
talking to anybody I would never tell
any of my family oh yeah so they never
even had it really they could never wait
no no no no no no because I had two
sisters right and they were like they
were at that age where they just had to
[__] put their nose in everything
right they already want to know
everything and then you know I'm sure
that my mom was just like she was a
nightmare to deal with as far as like
bringing a girl home or something like
that but even then like I wasn't really
like talking to anybody too seriously
dude my sister did not approve any
cheers yeah what would she tell you
until Nikki honestly like she was like
oh she was the first person that they
were like yeah she didn't like none of
your girlfriends nah she didn't why what
was she she was compared to herself is
that one yeah I think she was just like
trying to preserve her station
[Laughter]
I actually wish that everyone had like
uh brothers and sisters not so they
could [__] them but I think it's
important to be able to what would you
do with them it's important to have
uh uh like like a female's perspective
yeah I agree I agree or like a Brother's
perspective on a guy because like they
can't see the same [__] oh right and
then so it's like backup and you you
trust their opinion exactly because they
got your best interest in mind if
they're not trying to [__] you first but
like you know it's like that's a big
thing if they're jealous and they're
like he's mine tough right but she
probably had your back like yo none of
these girls are [__] good yeah I know
but you're just like they're not good
enough for you but they got titties
though yeah your sister's not good
enough no you can't all right yeah yeah
and then the brothers will back up the
sisters too like yo that guy's a sleaze
back why the [__] are you with him well
my brothers are younger than me so it
was different right so my sister's my
older sister so like I trust everything
she has to say oh my younger brother is
like I was the example for them
that's rough but were you the were you
the brother for the sister though when
the type of guy she brought around were
you like the brother that was like I
don't know about this no because she
didn't really bring guys around like she
was like a square as [__] she's a
veterinarian to this day but she didn't
want to make you jealous huh swear no
but she's the kind of vet who's like hey
like we gotta do X-rays I know that
sounds like nuts to you in like a scam
but like we have to do it because like
unfortunately I can't get like any kind
of like diagnostics from like they can't
talk to your [__] animals does she
practice out here no she's in um San
Diego I would bring my [__] dog to
yourself honestly like my sister is like
the the best one you could ever have
like as far as I know because some vets
are [__] cares too much yeah she like
adopts oh like she [__] thinks people
like bring their cat over like my cat
pees on my couch we put her asleep
my sister brings it home dude
but there are people like that though no
and my sister's doctor tutor she has so
many [__] animals it's like holy it
sounds so hot dude if I if my dog ever
has an ailment pray to God no amen I'm
gonna bring him here you guys if the
care boys ever have an issue please let
me know because I'll call her up and she
she doesn't she's [__] like the best
at the best got it and my
brother-in-law's really good too he's a
biologist he's at UCSD and uh do they
ever collab yeah yeah to drop a mixtape
together you want to make a freak of a
horse
but no like there she is like really
really good so if you have questions
like my neighbor's like hey I have
there's some ash on my dog's belly I'm
like sure cool so any other girls that
you brought around was your family like
not cool with any of them all of them
except for Nikki what do you feel like
set the other girls apart or what set
Nikki apart from the other girl sorry um
Nikki is interested like like you know
she's proactive yeah well and you know
how people like that will tolerate
tolerate instead of being interested
yeah like Nikki was interested an effort
you mean like she was interested in your
family yeah so the other girls were like
snobby or what was it like there was a
night where like I brought Nikki over
and then I fell asleep like 10 30
because I was so [__] tired because
we were traveling all day and then Nikki
set up with my mom for like 3 30 in the
morning they were just talking with each
other and like they have a bond since
that's amazing that's a build a
relationship yeah it's an unbreakable
Bond yeah that's cool and and like um am
I my my Nikki loves my mom so much and
she talks about it all the time that I'm
like man it like it like just [__]
you know just feels good it just feels
warms your heart yeah yeah it does it's
like a team she ever feel threatened by
her sister
um only when my sister's wearing her
padded bra damn
does your family do they all your dad
speaks perfect English yeah yeah do they
have a bond with Tiff or no yeah
definitely like my a good one yeah too
like you know earlier it was kind of
like
a little I don't want to say weird but
it was just like
she didn't
Tiff kind of didn't know how to like
interact with my family sometimes
because my family's kind of like they're
a little funny you know I mean they're a
little funny in their own ways they're
quirky they're not like bad people or
anything it's just like they expect a
lot you know what do you mean like
specula
um they're Chinese yeah yeah like they
expect a lot out of who you're bringing
over like growing up my mom would be so
particular where I wouldn't want to
bring my friends over because if they
said hi the wrong way oh yeah my mom
would be like yo [__] these fools yo
like who the [__] are you bringing this
hoodlum in my house but over we're like
dude it's so Chinese she's like yo [__]
these fools yeah yeah yeah she's like
hey yo like these guys because honestly
I would have my friends hanging out at
my house my mom would come in say hi and
they should be like can you guys speak
to the other room I'm like yeah no and
then she'll pull me to the side she goes
how come no one stood up on adult
internet
is there anything like Savages or have
they ever been civilized are they stupid
and I was like I didn't know this was
[__] like main Dynasty you gotta
acknowledge the hell out of other people
you have to yeah and there'd be all
these like invisible rules that you
wouldn't know until the rule was broken
and then it would be a whole thing like
confusion standards yeah yeah yeah right
right right and it took a while for me
to like understand that you know growing
up it's confusing too because some of
the baddest dudes understand that and
then some of the nicest guys don't bro
goes over the [__] head right so it's
like it's a shift when they go to your
house like you can have some [__]
like a murderer stands up and your mom's
like Oh I like him
until he can keep his ax over here he
talked to me for like 20 minutes he's a
sweetheart but yeah she has a
relationship with my family and like we
hang out we do things together and it's
gotten like it's gotten way better over
the years like and it wasn't like ever
bad but it was just they've grown closer
they know how to like interact with each
other and it's been really cool to see
over the past couple years for sure
um but my dad has been out of like the
country for a really long time but he's
been back recently yeah and he Tiff
loves my dad like even my dad loves
talking to her even though she thinks
he's like I remember one time we were
eating Korean barbecue and he was like
he's like uh hey Tiffany like what's
Guatemalan food like and then she's like
um I don't
I don't really know I've never really
had it he's like
what you're not Guatemalan
she's like I'm Salvadorian yeah and he's
like he's like oh oh [__] sorry he's
just like that [__] dude my dad he's
like he's easy to talk to he's easy to
get along with he's like you he's like
way more chilling it's like some Nick
[__] right there I would love to have
your dad on JK I would love it I'm gonna
try to get him on even though he's shits
all over the show he would immediately
go why are you guys using such shitty
exactly I would love it he's like what
the [__] you guys talking about on here
put next down the hot tea let's go no
but uh with all the celebrities that
he's met too exactly I know Indiana
Jones are you [__] kidding crazy he's
like the closest thing to a living
legend that I know but but yeah like you
know nothing too crazy I got I got made
fun of Hardcore for my first girlfriend
in high school because it was when I was
15. she was one of I think two Filipinos
I've ever dated my whole life and I
remember my my mom's very sweet she
doesn't mind who I'm dating she's very
accepting my dad usually doesn't care
and this time he was like I don't know
if it was the first time but he really
gave a [__] and he was just like no I
don't like her I don't like her really
Dad and I was like why usually it's the
moms and I thought it was because she
was Catholic and I was like yeah I'm
we're I'm 15 like it's not I'm not
getting married or anything and he's
like no I don't like it uh she has
homeboys and I don't like that because
she was like because and I was like what
do you mean because she she looks like
this is 2 000 uh let's see I was 15 so
this is like 2 000. so she's wearing
spaghetti straps and like [__] low
rider bell bottoms like a gangster
Filipino girl but she was a sweet girl
but it was a style great girl yeah she
had the [__] bell bottoms and then
the little liner around the lipstick
yeah yeah the flare
older sister who hung out with a lot of
like Filipino gangsters and she was like
but everybody did like so hot but then
my daughter were you motorboating those
titties or what I think that might have
been the furthest I ever went with her
yeah but then uh my dad was giving me
all his [__] and I was like why and then
turns out
he was doing that because he knew that
she and I are cousins
what the [__] yo what the [__] is going
on are you motorboating your cousin what
a bomb you dropped ways like through his
through my dad's side okay there's a lot
of questions so I'm just gonna start
somewhere with them why would he not go
that's your cousin I don't know maybe he
didn't want to break that's a really
good question well because here's the
thing it's like in Filipino uh family
trees this is a common thing that
happens everybody got cool yeah I just
didn't expect it could happen uh
inter-religiously
you just assume most people same
religion Filipino you could find a
connection I thought oh she's Catholic
there's no way related but my dad
um we're related through marriage like
one degree between us God so not blood
not blood oh but enough to get roasted
like crazy yeah I'd roast you yeah yeah
it squeeze your dad and go like can you
write on me Diana May is
is
no it took so it took my it took my
other cousin who's named Chad Chad is um
he's one of the guys he's one of the
owners that kind of fit kind of fat he's
my cousin he's your cousin what a small
world he's the cousin between me and her
and he was the one who she's our second
cousin yeah and he was like no he said
through marriage through marriage yeah
they they married and there's like a
there's a link there so there's no blood
relation no blood no blood no blood and
then he's the one who told me I was
getting kind of spicy though as she was
a kid he's like he's like a little kid
at the time and he's like he goes hey
your dad said your your day your cousin
I was like what are you talking about
and then like uh and then out of nowhere
I guess my dad was making fun of me
behind my back about it
[Music]
and then they started laughing at me and
then somehow like my the my friends who
go into the same church found out and
then at school they were all making fun
of us so it worked anyway when he was
trying to help you get away from that I
can relate to this your dad's kind of an
[__] he had a cousin I had a cousin
who was my second cousin uh-huh
she actually told people my school she
had a crush on me and destroyed me for
my entire Middle School destroyed you
now oh just everyone's like your cousin
[__] your cousin [__] oh [__] she
said she had a crush on you even though
it was like I'm excited did she know she
was a cousin huh she knew she was a
cousin yeah but oh that's not fair
because you didn't even do anything
exactly how did it destroy your
reputation because she liked me so it
doesn't matter the kids just talk and
like I was with disco for like a year
and she was like my first real kiss wow
oh Jesus doesn't [__]
I I Really Got It Bad like everyone was
good because it sounds it sounds worse
than it is yeah but like it sounds
terrible his first kiss was his cousin
we didn't know each other or meet or
anything until High School
I think you [__] know them too oh
really you know when you first like like
have pillow talk with your girl you guys
are laying down you're like just kind of
going through the list like also who's
like who's your first girlfriend was it
like oh it's my cousin actually no no I
forget and that's why he's with smack to
make sure that there is no relative
that's connecting you're not albino
Filipino are you
Lions Ryan's like laying with this chick
is pillow talk and he's like yeah do you
think like when your dad and like my dad
were hanging out like they were like
fishing and like it was like good they
had a good time
because like they're because
we're related and because it's that
remember Kathy Aquino she's your cousin
oh my God same like family tree but
interesting we're not like related like
that but it's enough that your friends
and everybody who's not Filipino totally
thinks like oh wow you guys grew up
together we're in the same crib and [__]
you guys don't even look alike yeah
I didn't look anything like this chick
my my second cousin but she told one
person that was enough to destroy me
yeah I suppose in junior high waiting
for something exactly yeah for those two
years it was like the most dramatic in
junior high and there was this chick I
like named Adrian and she was like I
heard that like your cousin likes you
and I was like oh dude if it was like
burning my future
so what I I love her
so what I love her
eyes on that Hill for no reason I should
have ghosted my cousin because of it I
was like you're dead to me [__]
how dare you you know what that's more
harsh back in those days to go somebody
yeah yeah because that's like you'd have
to do it face to face or they wouldn't
know yeah I saw her all the time I
[__] ignored her because I was like
whoa I was like you know that I am with
my sister you can't do this
I think it's better and better if nobody
found out would you seek that out would
you guys have talked and hung out wait
who your your cousin your second cousin
no it was unrequited
about blood though have you guys fixed
it since then or no I don't know that's
a good question yeah like do you guys
still see each other at Family Feud
she's giving you eyes at the cookout I
don't see the Millers ever dude you guys
do you guys avoid each other during the
square dance partner changes you gotta
cool with me later because like YouTube
started doing [__] and then she called
me later and I was like cool to her
because I had to be yeah but like I
don't hate her I just didn't forget that
[__] and I don't forget I think I'm
Petty yeah I'm a [__] tiny little
goat brain and just don't forget things
but she's like man Steve's looking real
good these days
I didn't write in my wedding for example
oh you did it no wow because you'd be so
jealous the whole time yeah yeah she
probably she would have objected yeah
she's like that should be with me
you were German Royals we would have
been together kept it in the family she
goes I have a video idea cousin's gone
sexual actually
you want some a layer of Truth
um she was there the day that that guy
put hands on me
like like she was there she was there
and then I tried to explain to her like
why I didn't want her to hang with this
dude afterward but then she like liked
it she had like a gay friend and like I
was like [__] this [__] I was like
strike [__] seven which which guy
yeah what happened which guy what
happens when you hit strikes up if I had
hands on you the guy that you made
you're like hey Steve you like how it
felt the piece of [__] pretty sure
[__] you don't remember one of your most
Banger hits yeah that's a good hit it's
actually really good it made me like
this place
it did because I was afraid I was like
oh man I'm gonna take the I'm gonna like
make the room more intense but it was
like a nice little tension reliever
actually it was a joke
[Music]
foreign